Hi, I am Olivia Wilde, and I'm
chatting with Laura Kosann.
Hi.
The 2021 Nicholl Fellow
for her excellent script,
The Ideal Woman.
The Ideal Woman takes place
during the Cuban Missile Crisis
in American suburbia
and follows a 1960s housewife
who used to be a very famous
film star in Hollywood,
but whose career was cut short
and follows her as
her carefully crafted
house of cards world
begins to tumble
as she's pitted
between two identities.
Nice to meet you.
So nice to meet you.
I think they might have told you
I have an eight week old baby, so-
No one told me that.
that if they're like bags
under my eyes,
Not at all.
I loved your script.
I really, really enjoyed The Ideal Woman.
I find screenwriting to be the most kind
of confounding part of the process.
And I'm curious,
where do you find your inspiration?
My writing is very much like this
process of immersion,
like with The Ideal Woman,
you know, the 1960s.
Like, I live there,
you know, while I'm writing it.
So I, it's everything I consume.
It's everything I read.
It's everything I listen to.
But that step to sort of
put it onto the script page
is that part that it's like, I'm
not ready, I'm not ready, I'm not ready.
And then suddenly when I'm ready.
It just like pours out.
That’s really interesting it's almost like
a method acting approach to writing.
It's an interesting interaction
between screenwriter and director
when you can sync up.
It is an amazing feeling.
But that's why, you know,
you're such a role model to me
because, like the fact
that you direct, I mean, it's
something that I want to do in the future.
I don't know. It's just, it's, it's
so exciting to talk to you.
Wow, that was bad.
Oh, sorry, guys,
I just, like, I had to gush
there for a second.
With something like
The Ideal Woman.
When you write it,
is the goal to direct it?
Ideal Woman's one
that I'm always like,
Oh, I would love
to direct this, but I also
the opportunity to have an
incredible female director, direct
one of my scripts would be such
an invaluable learning process.
And especially, as you said, if you have
someone that kind of speaks your language,
I always wonder what that process
is like kind of handing over this baby.
And I always wonder if like
actually the writer is like,
”But I could do it better.”
Maybe it’s a little of both.
I think it's probably a little of both.
What's your pitch process like,
and do you find yourself writing complete
screenplays and then pitching them?
Or do you pitch ideas first?
I find now it's both
because I do tend to really love
to just like, write the screenplay.
And I've been told by producers
like, “Okay, wait, wait, wait, we don't
we don't need the script just yet.”
I’m like, “No, but I know exactly
what will happen
from start to finish, and I can
play out the whole thing for you”
As a writer, sometimes
you have trouble
like dialing it down to
this seed of an idea.
I was watching you,
You were talking about Booksmart,
and I think you said
“it's like Training Day for high school”
I'm not good at that.
The movie I just directed,
The closest I got was
describing it as
”The Feminine Mystique on acid.”
Not really descriptive.
Like that doesn't answer
any questions, but for me,
I was like “It makes total sense.”
My other question was about how you
how you handle taking notes.
It is this living, breathing thing.
And I feel like as a writer,
you want it to be this thing
that's like ever-changing in a sense.
Speaking of progress,
you as now a new mother.
How has it shifted your perspective
on working in this industry?
It's a challenge, of course,
and it's so new, by the way, like he's
literally eight weeks old on Thursday.
It's crazy to think about, yeah,
but I hope that I'm able
to still be present with my son,
but also do the same thing.
And I think that it's challenging to do it
while being a mother,
and it needs to be talked about more.
I does I think, that's why
I ask it so candidly.
Like, do you have fears
because it is all possible,
but we have to leave space
to also air fears.
I have two kids.
I will tell you, like becoming a mother
makes you much braver because like,
look what you did eight weeks ago.
I know. Thank you for saying that.
Yeah, you're a goddess and a superhero.
And now you can write anything you want.
Thank you so much
and thank you for your time.
You are a huge inspiration for me.
I jumped 20 feet
when I found out
we were chatting, so...
Wow
and postpartum no less.
That’s a real, that’s a real feat.
Yeah.
Okay well, I look forward
to meeting you
and going to jump back
into my post process,
which you totally understand.
Thank you so much.
Bye, everybody.
Wow. Oh, my.
Did that just happen?